early morning queues outside a
Singaporean polling station
this presidential election appears to
have generated more excitement than
those in the past and voters Keen to get
in and exercise their Democratic rights
yeah I'm really happy shows that we are
truly a democratic country and three
great candidates and the best man wins
yeah Singapore has really blossomed a
lot you know very highly Technical and
professional and democracy has now
blossomed with it I hope so
but from the from the way it is run I
think everything seems to be open
recent constitutional changes have
ensured a greater choice on the ballot
although the president is a
non-political post some think this could
become a referendum on the ruling party
we're looking also at at an electorate
you know that is more desirous of
political diversity maybe even some
contestation you know in a one-party
dominant state
few people here question the success of
a city-state that's now one of the
richest countries in the world
but the economic development has not
been matched by political change and
this election could be an indication
that voters would like a little more
choice now with the official results in
it's clear the establishment candidate
won with a very comfortable
marginatnam a former deputy prime
minister a senior minister
now the new president Tony Chang Al
Jazeera
people
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera